today I want to tell you about a really
interesting crypto currency trading
platform called puka Mex this video was
sponsored by puka Mex and you can find
out more about the project using the
link right underneath this video so puka
Mex is a leveraged crypto currency
trading platform that they say is
created for the traitor by the trader
and they say it's their firm belief that
as the crypto market continues to mature
we're going to see a shift towards
leverage platforms like puka Mex
the project has been about 14 months in
the making
and it's come a really long way since it
was first conceived and today they're
sitting on a fully working product
demoing the entire suite of features
they've deployed a smart contract that
has distributed tokens to private sale
investors they have a demo of the
revenue distribution contract and they
also have a social media network of over
15,000 followers combined as well as an
official partnership with go chain so
they've already made a bunch of progress
and recently they on-boarded a variety
of experienced advisors who they say are
working closely with some of the
industry's leading projects these are
advisors that puka max says have brought
them a significant amount of value and
that you'll see this reflected in their
updated token ah mcc's model that's
about to come out
Puka max says their current fundraising
is to support their continued creation
of a trade and matchmaking engine
capable of handling high trade volume
for the long term to hire key people
rent a new office space execute their
go-to-market strategy which they say
will include an IE oh and they already
have agreements with multiple exchanges
so they have some really exciting things
going on right now it's been a
fascinating project to follow so let's
talk about some of the problems that
puka Mex wants to solve a lot of trading
platforms and exchanges that are out
there today are built on really old
infrastructure so during times of high
volatility when the performance of a
trading platform matters most often
they're not as reliable or as responsive
as they really should be
and there's many existing exchanges that
are also really difficult to navigate
and use big learning curve that's
implicit in
using them exchange security is also an
issue we see all the time and sometimes
with many exchanges the only solution is
to store your crypto off of the exchange
which sort of defeats the purpose and
the convenience that the exchange was
meant to provide in the first place most
exchanges out there are only available
in English or a couple of other
languages which does no good for a huge
number of crypto traders out there that
don't speak those few languages and then
another big problem that we see with the
exchanges is very high trading fees
exorbitant in some cases and those are
fees that the exchange will often keep
for themselves traders never see the
benefits that come from the collected
fees so here are puka Max's answers to
these problems one they've developed the
trading platform that shares revenue
with the user base it's a platform where
the exchange itself is not the only one
that profits from the fees the point of
puka max is to give back to its users
through its 25% monthly revenue share
back to token holders it's a high
leverage professional-grade platform but
it's also easy to use it the intuitive
interface is clean trading actions or
streamlined
users have immediate access to all of
the data and controls that they need to
make quick trading decisions they
actually say that it can be trusted to
be reliable even during high volatility
times and in a fast-moving volatile
market the last thing traders need is a
platform that crashes or freezes or
slows down during critical trades and
puka max says that their innovative
infrastructure that has built in
redundancy it has a single points of
failure was designed to eliminate
unscheduled outages so that trades can
be processed instantly even when there's
peak demand and volatility languages
there will be support for a wide variety
of different languages this is actually
a very underappreciated issue in the
crypto trading world for example Arabic
is a core language that will be
available on puka max it's used by a
substantial portion of the global
population it's becoming an increasingly
important part of the online world yet
there are very few exchanges out there
that support it which limits access to
crypto exchanges to an entire region of
the world
Puka Mecca says one of their biggest
priorities is also user security so an
insurance fund will be in place for
guaranteeing trades if there's ever been
a time where we need improved crypto
trading platforms it's now the crypto
market cap has grown by 700 times since
2013 there were over a trillion dollars
in trade volume last year we've seen
lulls over the last year but much of
that has been attributed by some to
suboptimal trading platforms in and of
themselves platforms with problems that
puka max is aiming to solve and there
are actually arguments to be made that
leveraged trading platforms like this
could play a role in the solution for
crypto simplicity security reliability
speed these are the core tenets that
puka max says their platform was built
on I've been enjoying watching what
they've been doing and I'll be paying
attention to it going forward you can
check out for yourself much more about
puka max using the link right below
remember nothing in this video is
financial advice everybody should be
doing extensive research on their own
before making any decisions about
investment in or use of any platform